hi I'm Steve Clements and I have a
question is there any way to end the war
in Ukraine let's get to the bottom line
[Music]
exactly one year ago all-out war broke
out between Russia and Ukraine at the
cost of hundreds of thousands of lives
but it's a deceptive anniversary because
since Ukraine's independence from Soviet
Russia more than 30 years ago animosity
had been rising between the two
neighbors and there's been a low-level
war going on since Russia annexed Crimea
in 2014. the conflict has divided the
world into two main camps one of them is
strongly anti-russian and the other is
more ambivalent for many leaders in the
west including U.S President Joe Biden
the idea that borders and countries are
sacred and no one should be allowed to
erase them is worth fighting for the
rest of the world takes a more nuanced
approach citing hundreds of years of
shared history between the two Nations
Ukraine and Russia but with total
military victory for either side being
highly unlikely and no negotiations on
the table is there any way out of this
war how many more anniversaries of
misery is the world going to Mark and
for Ukraine and the West what does
Victory even look like
today we're getting two views on the war
in Ukraine one from Moscow and one from
Washington in a moment we'll be speaking
with Andre cortunoff director of the
Russian International Affairs Council
but we'll start with Admiral John Kirby
coordinator for strategic Communications
at the National Security Council in the
White House who's just returned from
Poland where he was with President Biden
Admiral Kirby thank you so much for
joining us today
my question to you after the president's
comments in in Poland is are Americans
hearing what our Stakes are in this
conflict in crisis
I believe that they are and of course
that was a main purpose of the the
president going to Kiev uh this week as
well as to Poland and delivering a major
address there in Warsaw to make plain to
the world certainly to the American
people but but to the whole world uh
what's at stake here uh with the war
going on in Ukraine and particularly
going forward now there's been an
incredible unity and support for Ukraine
over the last year sadly it's been a
year uh and now we're heading into our
second year hopefully it won't last much
longer but we've got to stay resolved we
have to stay United uh and the president
wanted to make that case directly to
people all around the world yeah uh
Admiral uh house Foreign Affairs
committee chairman Michael McCall is
asking for the administration to do more
to give more lethal weapons that give
longer range missiles to to to amp up
essentially our military support and
decide their other Republicans say do
far far less in fact do nothing that
what we invest uh in Ukraine is
distraction from needs in America adding
to the debt Etc I guess my question is
what's your directional course in
dealing with Republicans on this
conflict
can you buy camera and bipartisan
support for the kind of things the kinds
of things that we are trying to do for
Ukraine and it's we all get wrapped up
in the weapons and the systems but it's
it's beyond that it's also the
humanitarian assistance the financial
assistance
um and when you talk to the the new
house leadership you'll hear pretty
consistently from them uh like uh
chairman McCall you mentioned and
speaker McCarthy that they recognize the
stakes here and that they want to
continue to support Ukraine so we're not
taking that for granted of course but
the number of Republicans who are in the
opposite Camp are small and they are not
in the in the key leadership positions
we're going to continue to work with
Congress uh going forward we have enough
resources to get us through much of this
fiscal year uh through uh 2023 and if we
need to go back to Congress for more
hopefully we won't hopefully this will
be over but if we have to uh we'll do
that and we can do that with the
confidence that again leadership on both
sides of the aisle are very supportive
of this number two uh and and this is
not unimportant is we we recognize that
that there are even there are American
citizens citizens who are like likewise
asking many of these questions about
continued support for Ukraine uh and I
would say that most Americans understand
the idea of Independence it's a founding
ideal here uh it's something near and
dear to all our heart our hearts and
it's important to remember that that's
what Ukraine is fighting for it's very
Independence Mr Putin has not backed off
his strategic goals of subsuming Ukraine
into Russia he still wants uh Ukraine as
another Province uh so it's fighting for
the very idea of Independence something
that all Americans can understand and
number two if we've waver if we flag if
Mr Putin succeeds we don't know what
he'll go after next and the cost in
Blood and treasure to the United States
as well as to our allies and partners
could be exorbitantly much higher than
what it has been in terms of the
resources we've applied to help Ukraine
over the course of this year let me ask
you a question and I'm not entirely
comfortable with but you know we have a
lot of um folks that are defining this
conflict as not just about Ukraine it's
about the future of the Norms between
nations they're imbuing it with lots of
sort of larger order questions I guess
my question is if so much is at stake
why do we fear so much escalating it if
the stakes are that high
because I think we can all understand
Steve as bad as this war has been for
the people of Ukraine and for Ukraine's
cities and towns their children that if
it escalates and becomes what Mr Putin
has claimed it has been falsely since
the beginning a war between the United
States and Russia or the Western versus
Russia or NATO versus Russia if it
escalates to that level it's not only
going to be much worse for the people of
Ukraine than it already has been it'll
be much worse for the European continent
our allies and partners potentially the
world it is important that we do not
seek a conflict with Russia and we don't
buy into Putin's propaganda that we're
already at that level because again I
think we can all understand that the
stakes of that kind of conflict would be
just exorbitantly worse for uh again
people of Ukraine our allies and
partners and the American people from
your perspective what are the
requirements for an off ramp or an end
game in this I know you've basically
said in the past that Vladimir Putin
could end this tomorrow by pulling the
military out and going home and end of
story but on a realistic basis is there
uh an end game or something that we
might begin looking for as we move
forward to this next year where there's
something other than another
never-ending War
we all want this war to end and as
you've rightly said we said it could end
today Putin would do the right thing
clearly Stevie shows no signs of being
willing to do that
and so president zielinski has put forth
a 10-point proposal uh and he has called
for a just piece we are working with his
team to see how that proposal can be
operationalized and there's still a lot
of work being done there but for
negotiations to occur both sides have to
be willing to do it and both sides have
to be willing to do it in good faith
president zielinski has rightly said at
this time he can't see himself getting
to the table given what Mr Putin
continues to do inside his country and
for Mr Putin's part he obviously isn't
interested in any kind of end right now
or negotiated solution as he continues
to bomb Ukrainian cities knock out the
heat turn off the power try to brutalize
the Ukrainian people steal their young
children and bring him off to camps
inside Russia and of course continue to
prepare for what looks to be more
offensive operations in the spring so
unfortunately sadly the the
environment's just not conducive right
now to a negotiated settlement what we
want to do Steve is as you've heard the
president say this we want to help
Ukraine's forces succeed on the
battlefield to continue the success that
they have seen in the last year so that
if and when President zielinski is ready
to sit down with President Putin he can
do so with the wind at his back he can
do so uh with it from a position of
strength because that's what he's going
to need to carry those negotiations
forward to some to some level of success
you know I've talked to many of your
colleagues John about who've had
meticulous attention on China and what
it's doing or not doing and over this
last year I guess a good story is that
the US has assessed that China has not
been a backstop in key Technologies in
military provision for Russia but there
is now concern that it might go over
that line do you worry that China that
we have intelligence that is now seeing
a shift in the Chinese Russian I guess
partnership or relationship in a way
where we will soon be real adversaries
to both of them tied together is that a
concern of yours
it is we want China to join the rest of
the International Community in
condemning this Invasion and not and
holding Mr Putin accountable and
certainly not doing anything that allows
his military to be able to continue to
prosecute this War uh against the
Ukrainian people uh now we have not seen
them uh devote lethal assistance to the
Russian military but we have seen some
worrying indications that they might be
considering that sort of move and I
think we can all agree and all
understand that that is not only not
going to be good for uh the Ukrainian
people if Russia can gain more lethal
assistance from China but it could
actually make this uh it could escalate
the conflict beyond what it already is
and nobody wants to see that uh so we
we've said that we've seen these
indications we'll we'll see and watch
what China decides to do uh but it is uh
concerning to us that uh that that China
continues to to appear to deepen this
relationship with uh with Russia at a
time when Russia should be made even
more of a prior than it already is when
Mr Putin should be held to account and
when his and where his troops should not
be inside Ukraine uh fighting again
against the Ukrainian people so we're
we're certainly worried about uh what we
see on the Diplomatic front between
China and Russia right now
I know this is a is an odd question but
I I guess my question is are we doing
enough you've met president zielinski
now a number of times you you've been on
the ground there you've been with the
president in Poland what is missing that
can help give zelenski more tools than
he has today well president zinski has
been unabashed as you know Stephen
asking for additional resources and
certainly having them uh show up faster
and we are working as hard as we can in
lockstep with him and his military to
give him a more advanced capabilities so
that um so that he can again continue to
succeed on the battlefield and and that
support has evolved as the war has
evolved when the tanks were starting to
roll towards Kiev everybody was talking
about the need for stingers and Javelin
anti-tank missiles and and of course we
we raced those to uh the front so that
Ukraine could win the Battle of Kiev
then in the spring when Mr Putin decided
he was going to concentrate on in the
Don Boston in the South and he pulled
his troops out of Kiev and kharkiv and
elsewhere it really became an issue of
long-range fire artillery and these
avanted highmars the advanced rocket
systems that we provided to give the
Ukrainian Ukrainian military the ability
to strike deep behind Russian lines
inside Ukraine then air defense
obviously Rose to the fore as Mr Putin
shifted tactics yet again and started
raining down cruise missiles on civilian
infrastructure and we're we're now
working to get them a patriot battery
and and there'd be more air defense
capabilities uh coming forward here uh
this week you heard the president talk
about that in Poland yesterday
um and now of course we're we're waiting
now shouldn't say waiting that's not a
good word we are watching as Russia
prepares uh for what will likely be
offensive operations in the spring and
so we are taking advantage of that time
to train Ukrainian battalions outside
the country on what we call combined
arms maneuver so this is open fight
fighting an open train using armor
artillery infantry all integrated with
air defense uh to help Ukrainian uh
units make their own offensive Opera
operations possible come spring so we
are not only evolving with the fight as
it evolved we're trying to get ahead of
where we think things are going to be in
the weeks and months ahead again all
designed to help the Ukrainian Army
succeed on that on the battlefield well
Admiral John Kirby spokesman for the U.S
National Security Council really
appreciate you joining us today thank
you
thank you Steve and now we turn to
Moscow where we're talking with Andre
cortunoff director general of the
Russian International Affairs Council
from your perspective in Moscow what is
the Topography of the geostrategic
consequences of this war look like from
your perspective a year into it I think
that if I were to limit myself to just
uh one word describing the uh
preliminary results of the conflict I
would say uh the uh what would be
resilience all the sides of the conflict
demonstrated some spectacular resilience
and their ability to sustain the initial
positions it is true for Ukraine which
turned out to be very robust and very
committed uh to resisting the Russian
actions uh it can be applied to Russia
because uh the Russian economic system
did not implode it did not collapse the
political opposition did not take over
uh Putin is still in control uh it is
related to the West which also
demonstrated a lot of resilience in
maintaining its pressure on Russia and
finally we can talk about the resilience
of the rest and the rest has clearly
demonstrated its unwillingness to take
sides in this conflict and uh to
consider this conference to be a global
rather than a euro-atlantic problem
well what you've just described are
conditions that can simmer for a lot
longer you you've kind of talked about
all the different parties uh no one
necessarily getting a knockout blow in
this continuing I'm sure you heard as I
did many speeches at the Munich security
conference saying that what's at stake
in this conflict is essentially you know
the the Norms of the liberal order in
the world you know the the the fate of
democracy you know in endowing this
conflict with lots of other issues from
Russia's perspective and I'm not
expecting you to be Russia but from
Russian's perspective what are the
stakes involved
um that we ought to be listening to
well the official Russian narrative and
I think it was emphasized by President
Putin today is that it is an existential
challenge to Russia uh Russia has a
conflict not with Ukraine uh but uh with
the quote-unquote collective West and
these Collective the West allegedly is
committed to destroying Russia to raise
interaction from the map of the world
that's why it is so difficult to look
for a compromise it is so difficult to
withdraw because the conflict is
perceived as existential as something
which is directly connected to the
future of Russia as an independent
country as a society if you wish as a
civilization
are we basically in you know the draft
of History seeing the influence of both
Russia and the United States go through
serious transformation and we may be as
unaware of it as Moscow maybe is unaware
of it
I'm sure that uh we will see a very deep
confirmation uh International
in the United States so just uh you know
look at who now runs our two countries
uh we have people in their 70s these
Generations will not stay in power
forever and uh there'll be some uh very
significant generational change I think
that maybe in a couple of years down the
road uh we'll have new people in power
who have different perceptions of the
world of their country's role in the
world but besides we should also keep in
mind that uh other countries are getting
stronger other countries are getting
more active other countries want to
become active players in the
International System and there is no way
Russia or the United States or anyone
else can stop it so the world will be
very different in a couple of years from
what we see now and maybe the only the
silver lining in this very dark
cloudy atmosphere that we have today is
that this crisis might become a catalyst
for changes uh which uh overdue changes
which are badly needed but which have
been delayed for quite a time I think
that we procrastinated for too long and
maybe now it's time to speed up is
Beijing thrilled with this moment are
they seeing you know their fortunes rise
as we have this proxy conflict uh with
Ukraine in Ukraine
huh it's hard to tell but I think that
uh first of all they believe that uh
time is playing on their side it was
time China will get stronger uh it will
get a more prominent Place uh in the
International System uh they do not want
uh to uh yield to the United States on
what is really important for them but at
the same time uh they did not want to
provoke the United States uh too
actively so I think that uh the Chinese
position would be uh let's wait and see
how this uh conflict evolves and then we
can probably try to participate in
working on a peace settlement but what
do you think would be on the laundry
list of items that Russian leaders would
need to see to begin taking a different
track
a lot will depend on
what kind of Ukraine we will see in
future I think that would uh Define uh
the territorial Ambitions of the Russian
Federation it's one thing if Ukraine
stays neutral or if uh you know Russia
gets some security guarantees it's yet
uh it's very different uh picture if
Ukraine's uh is uh deeply engaged with
the NATO alliance is heavily militarized
uh is explicitly interaction and then I
think Russia would probably insist on a
buffer zone or something like that but
it's hard to tell I think a lot will
depend on the situation in the
battlefield
you know one of the questions I have is
the tension between a global war and
people in Oklahoma saying hey our
schools are crumbling why are we
spending tax dollars on this conflict so
far away and not understanding
um that global stability matters to them
at home and this is classically we've
seen through human history at least in
the modern era what drives and fuels
populist movements we've seen this
frustration between the domestic and the
international really come into conflict
and I'm I'm interested in whether that's
part of the calculation here that that
the west from your perspective and you
know us very well whether our resolve is
shaky and wobbly in this conflict
because there are other choices that
societies want to make
uh it might be one of the considerations
uh in Moscow indeed we all know that uh
in the west the attention span of the
general public are is limited and who
knows what happens in the United States
uh uh after elections of 2024 uh who
knows what happens uh in Europe so there
might be some expectations that the
Western cohesion is not strategic but
tactical that it will be replaced by
some Rifts within particular States like
the United States or between states like
between the two sides of the Atlantic
Ocean uh so uh there might be some
expectations that
Russia can simply wait uh and uh observe
the Western Unity readily erode
on the other hand I think that Russians
resources are not limited Limitless
either
Russia might be resilient
but definitely uh it cannot sustain
Awards but at least will last forever so
I would say that there are significant
risks on both sides regarding the
ability to sustain this conflict for an
extended period of time and right now we
do not know
what side has more resilience and more
resolved and how this resolve will be
sustained
I'd just be interested as someone who
studied the United States so much what
blind spots if any do you see in
America's leadership in calculus right
now the bells of house in the world has
changed so dramatically uh since the
beginning of this Century it is
literally impossible to restore the
universe
strategically so I can only hope that
the United States will uh uh will be for
aware of the limitations not only of the
opportunities which it has right now but
also of the Strategic limitations uh
which exist in the world it doesn't mean
that the United States will necessarily
get weaker but it means that other
countries will get stronger and they
would
try to get their fair share of the
decision-making power in the world so I
hope that the United States will do its
best in practicing through
multilateralism by working both with its
partners and uh with its opponents and I
also believe that the United States
might reconsider you know this uh in my
view rather simplified approach to the
world uh dividing the road into good
democracies and better focuses uh the
world is not so black and white there
are many shades and many colors in the
world which have to be taken into
account
well with that we will finish great
discussion I always learn from you
director general of the Russian
International Affairs Council Andre
cortunoff thank you so much for joining
us today
thank you for inviting me
so what's the bottom line whether both
sides finally decide to sit down at the
negotiating table and make tough
compromises or not here are the two
things to keep your eyes on this year
one more and more folks in the Western
World will wonder why their schools are
crumbling and life is becoming more
expensive as their tax money funds this
war their worries may lead to more
populism and test the resolve of the
West to keep up its financial support
which is crucial for keeping Ukraine
afloat and two more and more folks in
the rest of the world may wonder why
this far away War even matters to them
many nations like India and China and
others haven't drawn lines of right and
wrong in this conflict and may resist
American pressure to isolate and punish
Russia as the world divides between two
big camps on Ukraine the risk to global
stability and international economic
growth could be staggering there's just
no sugar coating it this is going to be
a tough slog and that's the bottom line
foreign
[Music]